[Music]
CEL transport is the process of how
things move in or out of the cell
through the cell membrane there are two
broad categories of cell transport
the first category is passive transport
for a sell passive transport means it's
an automatic process that doesn't
require any input of energy
for example diffusion is a passive
process in which particles move either
into or out of the cell from an area of
higher concentration to an area of lower
concentration the cell doesn't use any
energy when this happens the second
category of cell transport is active
transport this is when particles move
from an area of lower concentration to
an area of higher concentration
when particles move against the
concentration gradient energy is
required often to allow protein pumps to
assist in particle movement why would
the cell need to move particles from a
low to high concentration and expend
energy to do it an important example is
seen in your heart muscle cells in order
for your heart to beat there are certain
molecules that have to move from an area
of low concentration to an area of high
concentration for those cardiac muscle
cells to work so the main things to
remember are passive transport happens
automatically with no energy required
while active transport needs energy for
it to occur
you
[Music]